[Música]
como será que uma jovem de classe média
alta privilegiada se transformou em um
ativista social
aos 23 anos esse é o conteúdo
aniversário de 12 anos que os pais
fizeram pra mim eu sei que não vai dar
pra lá que eu vou pra vocês
camila temos muito orgulho de você
continue sendo estudiosos respeitador e
educada
não esqueça que no respeito às pessoas e
construir uma sociedade igualitária que
amamos feliz aniversário a educação que
recebi dos meus pais foi você contribuiu
para trilhar o caminho foi trilhado até
hoje mas não foi a única
hoje vamos falar de um tema que para
muitas pessoas o tratamento legal aqui
política eu sei é um tema que talvez não
interessa à maioria de vocês
e é exatamente por isso que eu vim aqui
hoje eu acredito que pela sua bondade e
nossa política serem melhores
essa visão deve mudar muita gente acha
que questões sociais são um problema só
dos políticos e de quem trabalha no
setor público
se você é uma dessas pessoas eu preciso
te incomodar
na verdade eu vim cutucam a ferida ea
ferida a nossa inércia
a gente precisa entender que política
vai muito além do preconceito que a
maioria de nós tem e que no fundo cada
um de nós pode fazer política
então eu espero terminar o dia de hoje
tendo começado pelo menos um de vocês a
ge
eu cresci na década de 90 meus pais são
do interior de alagoas e do rio grande
do norte
minha mãe foi a primeira médica da
família e meu pai começou a vida
trabalhando como comerciante com o irmão
desde criança
segundo minha mãe meu pai era tão rico
não conhecer na boate ela pensou eu
nunca namoraria alguém como ele aqui
estou provocando ela pagou a bola né
inclusive ele está aqui hoje sabendo
disso pela primeira vez desde criança eu
sempre fui incentivado em amistosos
primeiro foram os gibis da turma da
mônica depois do filme da disney e harry
potter
levanta a mão quem de vocês também
pelo menos uma história da heroína
heróis que coisa boa fica feliz ao ver
que eu não sou o único
inclusive até hoje eu tenho a vontade
não realizada de praticar artes marciais
por causa de times como karatê kid
mas sou muito elogiada então na única
vez que eu tentei fazer muay thai e
rompe parcialmente o ligamento do
tornozelo e passei um beijo na cama eu
acredito que assim como eu você também
deve ter sentido essa vontade de ser uma
heroína de arões porque eles outra conta
desigualdade injustiça a opressão e
talvez seja por isso que a gente tem
dificuldade de enxergar como super herói
a gente começa a achar que para salvar o
mundo tem de ter superpoderes e talvez
seja por isso também que os filmes de
super-heróis anf bilheteria até hoje o
que eu acredito que na vida real
cabe a todos nós e nos super heróis
apesar de todas as mudanças no mundo de
hoje as conexões globais as novas
tecnologias quando se trata de política
a gente continua agindo de forma passiva
a gente continua acreditando que nosso
papel é unicamente votar e que no resto
do tempo cada um cuida da sua vida é um
ciclo vicioso
a gente acredita que política é só para
políticos e partidos com isso
determinante engajamento como cidadãos e
como sociedade nas decisões políticas
não nos representam e só não faço algo
contínuo
a gente fica manchado feito descrente e
se afasta esse comportamento se afastar
sempre prejudica o grupo é bem fácil
perceber se colocar uma equipe você já
deve ter passado por isso quando aquela
pessoa na faculdade do trabalho não fez
a parte dela e acabou jogando pra você e
para sua equipe se num pequeno grupo
esse comportamento se afastam do noso
imagine o que acontece na sociedade
inteira quando cada um de nós é um
exemplo
a gente esquece que sugere que a gente
tem hoje não condicionando para todo
mundo
a gente também tem responsabilidade
nisso nós compartilhamos a
responsabilidade com nossos políticos e
representantes assim como todos que
trabalham no setor público é fácil
apontar o dedo e falar que a culpa é
deles mas nós temos agido temos feito a
nossa parte a gente continua na 13a da
cidadania uma ação pontual lá e continua
em observação constante
se faz no dia a dia a gente observa nas
relações dos outros e reage quando é
necessário quando alguém fura a fila a
gente fica calado ou será que a gente
que fura a fila coletiva em seu
microblog na rua a gente avisa cttu hoje
pensa ah deixa pra lá alguém vai avisar
mas que vai avisar
segundo nicolelis público é tudo aquilo
que ela tem com a população ovo ou
coletividade
o senhor uma sociedade não só dos
políticos eles são nossos
eles afetam a minha vida sua vida o
tempo todo
a falta de fawcett adequação à falta do
kosovo - a sua oportunidade ea falta de
oportunidade perpetua a desigualdade são
problemas complexos e interdependentes
a nação por menor que seja pode ecoar
sistema de problemas
a gente pode e deve agir através de uma
nova cidadania uma nova cidadania desse
cidadão significa parar de terceirizar
responsabilidades e assumir a nossa
parte para já a mudança na sociedade em
2016 pode pedir um programa chamado my
life com ela no programa do governo dos
estados unidos voltado para jovens
líderes irá aumentar parte do trabalho
nas suas comunidades
até para o programa me considerava um
pouco estranha sonhadora demais talvez
até que eu fiquei na mesma fala como as
240 jovens como eu de vários países
origens raças e crenças e aí eu senti o
poder e as pequenas a fãs durante o
tempo que estive lá um link com um
pequeno papel mas como é importante que
mesmo assim eu continue
cada um tem seu motivo pra começar a
defender alguma coisa você não quer ser
tratado diretamente para o tomate como
eu falei eu fui e sou privilegiada da
escola particular teve plano de saúde
viagem todo ano e até incentivar o
esporte apesar de eu nunca ter sido
muito bom
eu vivi a vida inteira em uma posição
muito confortável eu poderia sem dúvida
nenhuma é seguir a minha vida sem me
preocupar com questões sociais poderia
se não fosse um download
eu percebi muito novo no privilégio
entender o que ele significava de saber
que essa palavra existia claro era
criança e com isso nasceu em 70 de
responsabilidade
meus pais sempre tiveram plenária
pública por causa deles já teve contato
com realidades e pessoas de diversas
origens algumas delas são paulo minha
família como mãe beta essa da foto
onde é que a índia nasceu dentro do mato
saí de lá própria enfermeira anos depois
como enfermeira ela virou minha babá e
depois minha mãe ela poderia ter ficado
no mato como ela disse assim como ela
tivera também vai a nana o zé luis
eles eram como minha segunda família a
gente tomava café da manhã - salva
jantava ria e brincava
eles me davam bronca e foi através dos
relatos deles que eu descobri o meu
privilégio na dificuldade de agendar um
exame para um médico na fila para
matricular os filhos na escola fica
colado madrugada para conseguir uma vaga
no desafio para chegar no trabalho
pegando 23 ônibus
eu aprendi logo cedo a qualidade de
conviver com o diferente e também como
nós mesmo diferentes somos iguais pela
família no sonho de ter uma casa própria
no orgulho da neta estudioso leveza dele
para não chorar e na esperança de dias
melhores e já sabe com que a taxa
começou a subir e ao longo dos anos eu
peguei um nome que sentia quando era
criança eu entendi o que é desigual dado
que são privilégios
o que é preconceito
via as experiências e amadurece em 2013
eu entrei em contato com o mundo do
empreendedorismo sempre protagonismo de
tomar atitude que aquela pessoa corajosa
que dança sozinho quando todo mundo olha
e pensa que ela é louca pra mim a pessoa
louca é o que cansou de esperar e foi
assim cansada de esperar que eu comecei
o político que a idéia da política que é
ampliar o entendimento sobre o que é
política e quebrar o ciclo vicioso
quando a gente se afasta de fazer
política e se isola cada vez mais nas
suas vidas pessoais ano passado
palestrante em evento para jovens
universitários e falei sobre o pleito
que um deles levantou a mão foi o carro
e se daí ele disse à polícia que teve na
minha escola e acho que eles fizeram
mudar minha forma de ver política
hoje eu acompanho as notícias têm uma
opinião sobre anos
a gente trabalhou com cerca de três mil
jovens como até agora a gente sabe que
nosso trabalho só começou
até porque se não é somente sobre
a organização é sobre a cidadania ativa
que está faltando em cada um de nós
sobre sair do conforto de nossas vidas
privadas para entender o que está
acontecendo à nossa volta
sobre a ampliar a visão entender que
política vai muito além do que em meio a
notícias sobre parar e direcionar o
olhar para questões públicas entender
que nós fomos à política e à nossa falta
de ação também é política e ela passa a
mensagem que a gente não se importa
quando eu comecei o político que falava
dele pessoas me perguntavam a você
começou por dizer que quer se candidatar
nem vez quando isso acontece eu digo que
não tenho planos de me candidatar seu
confuso como se política funções
política é muito mais difícil imagine
que política é o círculo preto
esse preto e planeta e o círculo amarelo
é político institucional políticos
partidos tudo cabeça negativamente pela
maioria das pessoas de fora do círculo
amarelo todas as formas de fazer
política e lógica do círculo amarelo
está dentro do preto é bem simples o
amarelo representa o preto é que
significasse uma democracia
representativa e o preto somos nós
cidadãos da sociedade
quando a gente teve isso fica claro que
nosso engajamento pode quebrar esse
ciclo vicioso em que a nossa ação
importa
ninguém está preparado o suficiente nem
existe momento certo é que você aprende
depois que você começa a 11
eu simplesmente me permite ser guiada
pelo incômodo que sentia quando comecei
porque se você parar pra pensar você vai
ver o problema como grande demais
você vai sentir impotente vai ter medo e
vai paralisar a gente não tem tempo pra
isso é urgente a hora certa já passou
a gente precisa aceitar a nossa
humanidade nossas limitações e agir
assim mesmo a ser ouvidas e agora somos
nós humanos imperfeitos e cheios de medo
alguns meses conversando com a colega
entrevista ela compartilhou comigo a
frustração
ela disse a gente se entender que o
engajamento em uma causa leva de engajar
em todas as outras
está tudo bem disse pra mim mas o que
serve pra todos nós
a gente precisa reconhecer nossa
incapacidade de mudar tudo
nessa hora vamos esquecer os sinos
histórias de ficção porque se cada um se
engajar em uma festa todos nós ganhamos
com a sociedade é importante a
discordância debate saudável
isso leva à construção coletiva
as divergências precisa se encontrar é
assim que a gente vai favorecer a
democracia a realidade que existe hoje
não vai mudar sozinha uma coisa certa do
jeito que tá tá funcionando não tá
falando pra todo mundo mas está
funcionando e quando acontece uma
mudança quando faz o que está
funcionando mas quem justa ou escolher
de alguma forma é substituído por uma
nova um novo equilíbrio para que isso
aconteça é preciso engajamento de 25 da
população
essa foi a conclusão da pesquisa recente
da revista science
ou seja 25% dos brasileiros se engajarem
a gente tem a chance real de mudança não
é impossível
se tem algo que incomoda você e ninguém
fez nada para mudar talvez seja porque
você se a pessoa você se levantar e agir
eu falei no começo é que a minha
conversa com diferentes costumes
sentimento de responsabilidade de servir
à sociedade
a gente pode encaixar na fidelidade e
nossa história como forma de atuar
porque todos os lugares importam através
das ongs junto com os negócios sociais
resolver um desafio da sua comunidade e
na academia do quando futuros
profissionais
essas são grandes decisões mas como eu
disse todos os lugares importam
então você também pode fazer o que tiver
ao seu alcance através de pequenas
atitudes buscar a inclusão de forma
proativa no ambiente de trabalho abre
espaço e fazer parceria com projetos
sociais fiscalizar as contas públicas à
sociedade ou de fora de trabalho e até
escolher melhor de três que você compra
praticando consumo consciente
a idéia é construir uma rede de pessoas
diferentes lugares diferentes
somente assim somente assim a gente vai
conseguir ultrapassar as barreiras que
são muitas
conquistar o apoio que este precisa e
até trabalhar juntos para fazer a
mudança acontecer e você tem o seu lugar
você tem a sua voz e seu lugar ea sua
voz seu super poderes
o que eu espero é que a gente possa
construir juntos essa nova cidadania e
com ela transformar a sociedade nossa
democracia para melhor
afinal fazer política não é somente
sobre um carro de filiar a um partido
muito menos a votar a cada dois anos
política muito mais do que isso é só
construir pontes as diferenças sobre
derrubar muros quando este preconceito
sobre a levantar-se onde existem justiça
sobre criar oportunidades onde se
sobre gerar mudança onde existe inércia
e acima de tudo política tem a ver com a
gente olhar pra se perguntar
diante do que me incomoda que
responsabilidade eu vou assumir e que
superpoder vou usar pra agir e fazer
isso mudar
[Aplausos]